attention toutes les imitations
événement présente dans cette vidéo
c'est à prendre au milieu de cette vidéo
caricature la communauté française de
façon très très très exagérées
nous vous remercions pour votre
compréhension cordialement voir piquer
squeeze excuse moi mais leur le telle
caisse en majuscule à n'ai volé
[Musique]
ces partis sont mortels pour tak portait
était quelque chose te plaît portek
constate pas dit quelque chose de plus
grand fait quelque chose
javi venta je suis là je suis le mortel
nouveau texte en est comme un autre
c'est facile de le mettre un truc shot
il fait quoi
[Musique]
lui aussi bas pourquoi je peux pas
bouger
c'est quoi ce bug
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors tu sais jamais comment au nom
alors des forfaits le voilà thierry pons
halo halo wars tech
je suis désolé et je voulais pas de
stopper tu désirais en tête mais chez
qui c'est moi ils sont eux lancé une
grenade à teplice il désolé
transport aussi bien par bien de jouer
sur le wgo au nom des hackers et boit ça
suffit
ouais monique bonjour ou encore ça va
c'était violent
[Musique]